Even the most rugged and hardiest of men cry
sometimes. There’s no escaping the tear.
In fact, studies suggest that you probably
cry a lot more than you think you do. During
a study by the German Society of Ophthalmology,
they found that women cry on average between
thirty to sixty-four times per year, whereas
men cry between six and seventeen times per
year.
Women are actually biologically hard-wired
to be more susceptible to crying. Women have
sixty-percent more prolactin in their bodies
than men. Prolactin is a reproductive hormone
which is also found in tears and is partially
responsible for women being more prone to
tearing up. On the other hand, testosterone,
a hormone which is more abundant in males,
inhibits crying.
However, this difference in the frequency
of tears shed between genders, doesn’t come
into effect until the age of thirteen. Before
they are thirteen, both girls and boys cry
the same amount.
Men and women don’t just differ in how frequently
they cry; they also cry for different durations.
Studies show that men tend to cry for between
two to four minutes, whereas women cry for
an average of six minutes.
Maybe this is why in almost every culture
on Earth it is more socially acceptable for
Women to cry than Men. Certain cultures actually
shun crying altogether, for both genders,
seeing it as undignified and infantile. Despite
the negative connotations they may carry,
tears are most certainly, a force for good,
they can call others to help you and even
heal you from within. But why do humans cry
in the first place? Let’s find out.
They may all look the same on the surface,
but there are three different types of tears,
and they’re all quite unique. The first
kind of tear is basal tears. In all mammals
the cornea of the eye is continually kept
wet by basal tears. Our eyes are some of the
most vulnerable and sensitive parts of our
outer body, so it’s incredibly important
that they are protected at all times. The
basal tears ensure our eyes are well protected
from bacteria and irritants.
Basal tears are made up of three distinct
layers. The first layer which sits directly
on the eye’s surface, is the mucus layer.
This helps the tear to spread out and coat
the entire eyeball, it also keeps the eye
moisturised.
The next, the middle layer, is the aqueous
layer, consisting mostly of water. It contains
vitamins and nutrients, keeping the cornea
healthy. This layer also contains salt which
acts as an antibacterial. This is why tears
taste salty.
And the third, outermost layer is the lipid
layer. This layer, made up entirely of oils,
acts as a sealant to stop your tears from
evaporating and keeps bacteria and other irritants
out. This layer also makes your vision sharp.
The convex of this oily film which coats your
cornea creates an incredibly smooth surface.
This helps to smooth out the natural bumps
and fissures on your cornea which can cause
blurred vision. This is why people get blurry
vision when they have dry eyes.
The second type of tear is the reflex tear.
These are only released when foreign particles
make contact with the eye which could irritate
or even damage the eye. For example, pepper
spray, tear gas, capsicum and of course onion
vapors. When these potentially harmful substances
make contact with the cornea, reflex tears
are produced to wash them away.
And finally, the last kind of tear is what
has perplexed scientists for so long, psychogenic
tears. When we talk about someone crying,
sobbing or weeping, we are usually referring
to psychogenic tears. These are tears that
are caused by strong emotions and physical
pain. It might be stresses at work or at home.
A family member passing away or perhaps a
pet. Or maybe a painful breakup with a loved
one.
But psychogenic tears aren’t exclusively
caused by negative emotions. We can also turn
on the waterworks when we’re overwhelmingly
happy or during an intense bout of laughter.
That covers all the different types of tears,
but all tears originate from the same place.
All human tears are formed in the lacrimal
gland; resembling a raspberry, it sits just
above your eyeball. It may be small in size
but it’s easily one of the most complex
systems in the human body. Tears are formed
inside it, then the small bulbs that make
up its unique shape, contract to pump the
tears downwards, exiting through little tubes
and ending up on your eyeball.
Your blinking is actually synchronised with
your lacrimal glands. When a new tear is released
from the gland, whether it be a basal, reflex
or psychogenic tear, you automatically and
subconsciously blink. This blinking motion
spreads the new tear evenly across the surface
of your eye.
Once a tear has covered your eyeball it has
two possible exit routes. The first is the
standard route, down the lacrimal punctum.
Think of this as the drain on your kitchen
sink. There are two lacrimal punctum in each
eye. They are located on the inside of your
eyelids. In fact, if you’re so inclined,
these tiny little drainage pumps can be seen
with the naked eye if you look really, really
closely.
Their sole job is to drain tears from your
cornea once the tear has served its purpose.
The tears that make their way down the lacrimal
punctum are drained down through your nose.
Which is why your nose gets stuffy when you
cry.
The second possible escape route for a tear
is of course down your cheek and then if you’ve
just gone through a break up, probably straight
into a tub of ice cream.
What happens when you fill the sink up too
high and it’s at risk of overflowing? The
water goes through the overflow. That’s
exactly what happens when you produce tears
faster than your lacrimal punctum can drain
them away. When the lacrimal punctum gets
overloaded, the excess tears have nowhere
else to go, and so they roll down your cheeks.
There is a system in your brain specifically
designed for dealing with emotions, it’s
called the limbic system. When we get emotional
the limbic system is activated. The limbic
system is hard-wired with our autonomic nervous
system, which is the control centre for the
function of our internal organs. The autonomic
nervous system is connected to and can control
every major organ in your body and thereby
the limbic system can influence and use this
immense power. This is how emotions can effect
us physically, for instance, emotions can
cause shaky and clammy hands, an increased
heart rate, sweating, stomach cramps and of
course crying.
But what’s the point in tears? Why is it
that when we get upset, the limbic system
in our brain feels it necessary to alert our
autonomic nervous system, to command the lacrimal
glands above our eyes to start rapidly producing
these weird, oily, salty drops of water?
Just like most human functions and behaviours,
there’s usually a solid, evolutionary reason
for having said function. If humans can do
something, it’s usually because there’s
a bloody good reason for it, or at least there
used to be. In this respect crying is no different
than most other human abilities; it’s believed
crying has its roots in evolution also. For
any ability to have survived the ruthless
critic that is evolution, it must, in some
way, be beneficial to our survival. But what
are the survival benefits of crying?
Well, there are actually two major benefits
of turning on the waterworks, which explain
why we have the ability to cry in the first
place. The first benefit is that it makes
us feel better. Get this, we don’t actually
cry because we feel sad. We cry to get over
being sad. Crying is our body’s own moral
booster and healer of mental wounds. 90% of
people report feeling happier and less stressed
after crying.
When you cry and someone says “let it out”,
they really mean it, because when we cry we
are quite literally crying our stresses away.
Stress-causing chemicals that build up when
we’re under emotional tension are physically
removed from the body in our tears when we
cry. Crying also stimulates the release of
endorphins in the brain. Endorphins are the
happy hormone, they relieve stress and lift-up
your mood.
The second benefit of crying is communication.
Before humans developed language, some of
the only forms of communication we had, were
basic noises, such as laughter and sobbing.
When our ancient ancestors hurt themselves
or were feeling upset, the sight of tears
rolling down their face will have spurred
their cohorts to come to their aid. This exact
same behavior can still be seen in babies
today. Since babies can’t talk they use
tears to communicate when something is wrong,
whether it be pain, hunger or tiredness. Or
perhaps they’re just missing their mummy.
Crying works so well to attract another’s
attention, because humans are genetically
programmed to feel sympathy for people who
are in tears. Psychologists demonstrated this
in a study where they digitally removed tears
from images of people crying and monitored
people’s sympathetic response. All the participants
judged the people in the images with tears
to be sadder than in the image without tears.
Studies show that crying is also good for
your health. A good sob lowers your blood
pressure and removes unwanted toxins from
your body. There has even been evidence that
crying can help to regulate your immune system;
in particular, during a study, it was found
that people who have recently had a good cry
were less susceptible to allergic reactions
and eczema.
Crying is one of the most basic yet powerful
forms of communication we possess. It can
heal your mind and your body, relieve stresses
and bring people closer together and there’s
certainly no shame in that.